[Music]
should i talk about my first ever nft
oh dude i'm so excited
you you've jumped in yeah i jumped in
and you know i i hesitated partially
because as as you know since you're
responsible for sort of pulling my
attention
i've been tracking this stuff for a
while right and and thankfully you got
me off my ass because you're like hey
i'm going to be doing this thing don't
tell anybody now we can talk about it
it's going to be called grails and
do you want to be part of it and do you
want to explain just very briefly what
grails was
yeah what it is and then i can hop into
it
yeah absolutely and and for those that
are listening that have no interest in
nfts or read the headlines out there
rest assured that i can tell you that i
too being so deep in nfts believe that
there's a lot of hype in the sector like
there's a lot of anyone armed with
photoshop right now can publish an nf2
to the blockchain and that means
that there's gonna be
a lot to kind of like sort through and
sift through to find the gems and but as
an underlying fundamental technology
it is a sound one and that there's
proven scarcity there's durability of
the asset meaning it doesn't degrade
with time
you can transfer it i mean there's a
there's a bunch of great things about it
that it will be around forever i have no
doubt
now that said
you know there was a lot of hype going
on into the world of nfts here and there
still is
six or so months ago and i thought to
myself like let's create an nft project
and call it grails
and the reason it was called grails it
was indiana jones and you know the holy
grail where he has to choose that cup
you know that very very famous episode
there i'll choose wisely and if you
choose the wrong one like you turned and
shriveled up and died right
so the
thinking there was that so much
attention at that time was on flipping
nfts oh i'm gonna grab this one i'm
gonna buy for five grand self for a
hundred you know also i'm just gonna
interject for a second also some people
refer to what they might consider like
the blue chip nfts as grail nfts there's
also that use of the word yeah continue
that's right yeah so the thinking there
was okay let's let's
put the emphasis back on the art and
allow people to look and consider each
individual piece
and then they have to make a decision so
20 artists
20 anonymous artists
all up on the site
as a member of my little group called
the proof collective you got to choose
one so you could go in there and just
pick one that you wanted and then we
would do the grand reveal and so
afterwards
we would reveal who the artists were a
hundred percent of the sale
of the nft and the royalties went
directly to the artist so i did not
profit at all
and um you weren't kind enough to say
i'm going to be one of those artists
that people have to guess uh if it's me
or not
yeah so there are 20 basically imagine
you go to a website there are 20
thumbnails of different types of artwork
most
if not all
artists who are established
did something that was
sort of
non-identifiable right they did
something a lot of them did something
completely different stylistically so
that you wouldn't know it was them
and
then people were guessing right so
there's a lot of speculation in various
discords and so on about who might be
the artist behind which piece
and when you initially offer it to me
and i'll i'll skip to the punch line
real quickly if people want to see this
what the output was i can go to tim dot
blog slash nft and i'll just forward to
a page on open see where you can see
what this looks like but i bounced
around a whole bunch of ideas and then i
realized wait a second
about a year ago a bit over a year ago
i wrote a short story and i've never
published fiction
anywhere so i've never had a fiction
blog post that i can remember i've never
published any fiction in book form i've
never
had a magazine article that was fiction
and i
i decided to
take that which is about
let's say 1400 words and the name of the
piece is how to start a war
i'll come back to why it's called that
because this was written keep in mind
more than a year ago so it's nothing to
do with the current conflict but how to
start awards fourteen hundred or so
words
and decided to make that the background
of this piece and then to layer images
on top of it so i ended up thinking
on my own and then along with this
designer lisa quine
about how to create something that would
actually
make a nice say poster in a frame on a
wall or a print and i wanted it i wanted
i needed some parameters i needed some
constraints i was like okay let me not
like blue sky this totally
it has to look
decent on a wall if someone put this up
on a wall
and
the it's called how to start a war
because it is based on a real experience
i had which
i'll let people read the piece who want
to read the piece so the only place you
can find this
first published fiction piece by me is
as this nft that's the only place you
can find it
and
it's an easy read but i the the way it
starts is
with someone handing me a business card
and saying if you want to start a war
call me and then it's like the whole
thing goes down a pretty deep rabbit
hole and most of it is
a composite but
true to life which made it pretty easy
to write
and
that's it i mean that's how
it started and uh it's been really a fun
experience for me so thank you kevin for
getting me off my ass
all the proceeds from this nft go to my
foundation so they'll end up funding
scientific research and other
initiatives related to primarily mental
health possibly
longevity and life extension or a health
span extension but predominantly mental
health and i feel really good about it
so it's been it's been a fun
little experiment and a chance to also
kind of understand how some of the
plumbing works you know what i mean it's
like if you want to like there's a point
you can only read so many books about
like playing soccer and then you got to
get out there and actually kick a ball
around right like you're not going to
really have a feel for it until you
start screwing around with the actual
mechanics and plumbing and having to do
things and you've had some good success
man one sold for 15 eth which is current
prices is around 50k
you know you've had a bunch of good
secondary sales yeah people were pretty
pumped yeah and it was fun to also have
the reveal right yeah so
so i think a lot of people minted
and
uh you know ultimately i i hope that
there will be some durable value because
it's not only my first nft but it's my
first published fiction piece so you
kind of get a two for one so we'll see
you